Halloween it is the one day of the year
that adults everywhere channel your
inner child and gorge themselves on tons
of those mini fun sized Jaffa bars
thinking that they don't count
spoiler alert guys those things add up I
mean come on don't we all wish we had
our twelve-year-old metabolisms
especially in a questionable outfit like
this or this thankfully I've got lots of
Halloween survival tips that you
definitely want to check out here but
today we're gonna be making a delicious
graveyard dip recipe that's actually
high in protein lower in sugar and so
much fun both you and your kids are
gonna love it
so let's get to it so first in a blender
or food processor I mix together
some soft tofu some ripe banana natural
peanut butter vanilla extract maple
syrups and cinnamon and I blend that
until it's nice and smooth then I just
layer that down into my serving dish
then in a bowl I mix together some
unsweetened coconut cocoa powder and
some cacao nibs and I layer that on top
of the dip and now it's time to decorate
for pumpkins I insert a little piece of
celery in to appeal to clementines make
banana ghosts I cut bananas in half and
make little eyes and a mouth with some
melted dark chocolate and then for
grapes I write our IP on a few
ladyfingers for dipping yes your kids
are going to love this stuff but guys
I'm like 30 years old and my mind is
seriously well I'm so excited about this
so guys if you liked what you saw be
sure to give it a thumbs up leave me a
comment below with whatever candy you're
gonna be stealing from your kids this
year be sure to subscribe to the channel
and I'll see you next time on Maddie's
kitchen